[Musik]
wir sind heute wie ihr schon hören könnt
auf einem Flugplatz hier in Linz am
Fliegerhorst Vogler
wir stellen die Herkules vor im
Hintergrund seht ihr die C130 des
österreichischen Bundesheeres mein Name
ist Villa Josef bin und
seit 2003 fliege ich mit diesem Flugzeug
wir haben seit 2003 Maschinen angekauft
für das österreichische Bundesheer im
Wesentlichen zur Versorgung der Truppen
die wir im Ausland Einsatz stationiert
haben und darüber hinaus für sämtliche
Transportflüge die zu erledigen sind
zusätzlich sind wir noch ausgestattet
mit einem sogenannten MediMax evakuition
Container das ist ein enorm Container
der als fliegende Intensivstation mit in
dem uns eingebracht werden kann und
autark beschäftigt werden kann durch
Intensivmediziner zur Geschichte der
Herkules kann man sagen das ist ein
lufttransporter Fahrzeug für
militärische Zwecke entwickelt in den
50er Jahren die das Bemerkenswerte daran
ist das ist eins der meist gebauten
Luftfahrzeuge überhaupt
2.500 Stück sind davon vom Rollband
geflossen und 1600 sind mittlerweile
noch immer im aktiven Flugbetrieb so und
jetzt schauen wir uns die Maschine in
einem Rundgang an und ich werde ein paar
Details erläutern wir fangen an hier
die Nasenspitze ist ausgestattet mit
einem Wetterradar das ist hier drinnen
eingebaut und verborgen und kann
jegliche Wettererscheinungen auf einem
Display da stehen man sieht das Buch
Fahrwerk
das ist ein einzelfahrwerk und es ist so
aus gestartet dass es auch für kurzstart
und kurzlandeigenschaften auf
unpräparierten Pisten verwendet werden
kann
des weiteren
sieht man die Triebwerke mit den
Propellern das bemerkenswerte bei einem
Propeller Luftfahrzeug ist dass die
Kraftübertragung vom Triebwerk über die
Propeller sehr schnell und früher
wirksam wird als im Verhältnis zu einer
Turbine wie mir vergleichsweise bei
einem Linienflugzeug hätten
jedes Triebe hat 4500 PS das heißt im
Groben reden wir von knapp 20.000 pS Die
hier dazu dienen das Luftfahrzeug zu
bewegen
zusätzlich kann man sehen wir haben hier
einen unterflur
außendankbehälter da können wir extra
noch einmal auf jeder Seite 5000 Liter
Sprit mitnehmen hier sieht man das
robuste Fahrwerk große Reifen eben zu
dem Zwecke dass wir auch auf einer
unbefestigten Piste ohne Probleme landen
können
wenn wir
den Rumpf entlang gehen sieht man hier
noch eine Besonderheit das sind
sogenannte erdeflektors die kann man
hydraulisch ausklappen und dann können
wir Fallschirmspringer über diese Tür
absetzen und das verhindert dass der
Fallschirmspringer zu früh in den
sogenannten
windfloh kommt
ein Teil der Herkules
das ist
zu einem zuverlässigen und einfachen
Transport Luftfahrzeug macht ist dieses
Rampen und dorfsystem im Hintergrund
diese Rampe kann hydraulisch abgesenkt
werden und über diese Rampe können
Fahrzeuge und Container aus und
eingeladen werden
das Flugzeug ist konstruiert worden nach
bestimmten Vorgaben des US-Militärs
beispielsweise wollten
sie haben das 92 Passagiere mitgenommen
werden können oder 64 Fallschirmspringer
da Frachtraum ist in der Dimension so
ausgestaltet dass wir einen
normcontainer aus und einladen können zu
diesem Zwecke wird auf diesem Boden ein
sogenanntes rollsystem angebracht auf
dem man dann die entsprechenden Paletten
über die Rollen hinein bewegen kann und
heraus bewegen und das geht dann
ziemlich schnell wenn wir weiter schauen
sieht man die Typen sind zu öffnen nach
oben hin werden sie aufgemacht und
bei beiden Türen können wir
Fallschirmspringer absetzen genauso wie
über die Rampe nach hinten zu diesem
Zweck müssen hier noch gewisse
Seile installiert werden um zu
gewährleisten dass die
Fallschirmspringer sich einhängen können
[Musik]
wir sehen hier die Ausstattung mit den
entsprechenden Sitzbänken die nach oben
geklappt sind die dann im Bedarfsfall
aufgebaut werden damit eben 92 Leute
Platz nehmen können oder eben 64
Fallschirmspringen das ganze findet dann
auch noch am Mittelgang statt so wie man
hier sieht
[Musik]
das ist jetzt nur ein Teil der nach
hinten verlängert werden kann wir sind
mit dem Rundgang fast fertig jetzt
schauen wir uns noch die linke Seite an
hier haben wir noch die Klappe für eine
sogenannte GTC das ist eine Turbine die
man braucht um Strom zu erzeugen am
Boden bevor die Triebwerke Rennen hier
sieht man das massive Propeller platt es
sind ausgestattet mit einem 4 Blatt
Propeller viermal die Besonderheit ist
der Propeller blattwinkel kann so
geändert werden dass der Pilot das
Flugzeug selbstständig auch nach
rückwärts bewegen kann am Boden
so jetzt gehen wir einmal hinein und
schauen uns einmal das Cockpit an wir
haben es mindestbesatzung einen Piloten
es sieht hier auf der linken Seite
Ingenieur und diese drei Männer bewegen
das sucht erzeugt und im Frachtraum ist
da noch notwendig ein Lot Master als
minimal Besatzung um dieses Luftfahrzeug
zu bewegen
in cockpit haben wir eine Ausstattung
die dem letzten Standard entspricht im
Groben reden wir von den sogenannten
premier reflight Displays man sieht hier
die Bildschirme für den Horizont und den
Kurskreisel wir haben in der Mitte die
triebwerksinstrumente vier Triebwerke
werden bedienen durch diese vier
Leistungshebel die vier Propeller
Wählhebel in der Mitte ein Display wo
man die Navigation darstellen kann und
wo das Wetter gerade eingespielt wird
Navigations sind die unabhängig wir
haben ein sogenanntes
Navigationssystem das in Zusammenhang
mit einem Global Positioning System
funktioniert haben wir hier zwei
Managementsysteme wie in einem
Linienflugzeug
des Weiteren beim Copiloten sieht man
dass hydraulikbedienung wir haben drei
Hydrauliksysteme die unabhängige
arbeiten und dann
sieht man das Arbeitsblatt vom Inch oder
Flugingenieur BMW wesentlichen
das sogenannte fuel Management im Auge
hat die
Maschine ist mit mehreren tanksystemen
ausgestattet die der
im Blick hat und bewirtschaftet des
Weiteren die Elektrik und dann noch
verschiedene Heizungssysteme und den
einzugssystemen
und die sogenannte Druckkabine das
luftfahrzeuger ist mit einer Druckkabine
ausgestattet mit zunehmender Höhen in
der Luftdruck ab und vor allem der
Sauerstoff Partialdruck und mit einer
Druckkabine kann man sozusagen
Bodendruck beibehalten auch in große
Ende Teil für den geneigten Zuseher am
Rande sei noch erwähnt ich bin
mittlerweile seit über 30 Jahren beim
österreichischen Bundesheer und wenn man
auf der Erzeuger Plakette von der
Herkules schaut dann wird man
feststellen können dass das Flugzeug
gleich alt ist wie ich
und jetzt schauen wir uns die Herkules
noch in der Luft an
[Musik]